no nobody
told me that what we were doing was as
you say uh against the rules uh that the
event in question was
something that we were going to do
something that wasn't a work event
and you know as i said in the house of
commons
when i went out into that garden
i i thought that i was attending
a work event
no beth but i want to begin by
repeating my apologies to
everybody for the misjudgments that
i've made that we may have made in
number 10 and and beyond uh whether in
downing street or throughout the the
pandemic and
i i do know how infuriating it must be
for people up and down the country in
view of the the huge sacrifices that
people have have made the way that
they've kept discipline and the way they
followed the rules followed the guidance
done the right thing to think that
that didn't happen in in number 10
dining street i carry full
responsibility for for what took place
but nobody told me i can absolutely i'm
absolutely categorical as nobody said to
me this is an event that is
against the rules uh that is in breach
of uh what we're asking everybody else
to do i should not go ahead what i
remember is going out into that garden
for a short time and
uh 25 minutes or so
thanking staff who had worked on a
coveted who were continuing to work on
covid
and then going back to my to my office
and all i can say is you know in
retrospect as i said to the house of
commons beth you know if i had my time
again
uh i would not have allowed things to to
developed in that way and when i went
out into that garden uh yes i should
probably have told people uh i should
have looked around and said well we've
got to go back indoors or this isn't the
right way
to do things but
and i i apologize for for that but i i
hope that people will understand the
circumstances we were we were operating
in but
i i've just got to ask people to to wait
for for sue grey to report this because
this is important this is the first time
we've seen you since reports emerged
in the daily telegraph not denied by
down street about two boozy parties held
in the garden in the buildings of number
ten the night before prince philip's
funeral when the country was in national
mourning
was having to apologize to the queen
about those parties
the night before she put her husband of
over 70 years she laid him to rest was
that a moment of shame for you i i
deeply and bitterly regret
uh that that that happened and i can
only uh
and renew my apologies both to
uh to her majesty and
uh to the country
uh
for for misjudgments that that were made
and and for which i take full
responsibility